these beings have been around for so
long they must be in they must be so far
beyond like wondering about our dna or
wondering about like what our spleen
does i think it's going to be
probably
unnerving probably complicated probably
a lot that we don't know and so the idea
of the government just coming out and
saying hey look what we got before they
know what it is doesn't make any sense
to me and i tell my friends this i go if
someone like jim
caught some dudes sneaking a nuclear
weapon you know through the border uh of
canada somewhere into the states you
know are they gonna stop and tell us all
about it and really just talk about it
or are they gonna go and try and track
down the guy who he was working with
where he got the parts where the device
is gotta you know goes on and it might
take some time now imagine if that
device was like handing an iphone to a
cow and the cow was like i gotta figure
out what this iphone is so i think that
the logical steps that one would take
are exactly kind of what's happening
which was
a number of years trying to figure out
something trying to come up with a plan
that helped understand it or whatever
and then it's like okay now let's create
a proper organization to start getting
more data and letting people know that
the data is real and that we need to
study this and then over time being able
to say this is what we learned you know
it's real and now we're studying it and
this is how they fly and it looks like
they might be doing this and that you
know and so i think we're doing the
logical steps now that might one day
lead to
we've collected some stuff you know but
i don't think that if they even if they
did
i wouldn't knowing what i know about
this subject which isn't like a lot i
feel like it's a lot but but who knows
um because they say like studying space
is like if we were to study the oceans
it's like we know a half a cup of water
of the oceans that's how much we know
about states yeah so i just i think this
is i think you're seeing
a rational logical progression of
something extremely complicated
starting to be formed to come out after
a long period of time of digging in and
trying to wrap their heads around it